so many podcasts with a certain tone not
at the end of the football season is
well maybe that's something we should
cover this weekend just we don't usually
at home no but I feel like this weekend
it's almost vital that we do because
it's big for a lot of people I mean
suppose does a Liverpool fan getting
tough for you be quite habitable that'll
be pretty good I mean you know are you
gonna be placing any bets this weekend I
usually do if I am I look at bet yeah
partial to a bet
I don't - yeah yeah Gobert lon I'm a
little pool obviously I'm going to be
using quick this weekend
what's hurt for my bets this weekend
yeah I'm going to be because when you
place a bet you stand the chance of
having your odds quest or you're ruling
us no I was just watching enough if
there it's sometimes a quick might be a
small boost say or what is quiff well
it's an app that you can download which
I probably will be making sure is in the
description so you can go and analyse
have you done a Burton sponsor not hope
well why'd you got also just reading
some text from the guys a quick I told
you not do this without telling us with
you if you get the app then I can show
you maybe I'd help to supercharge your
odds but uh do you want to do that okay
yeah okay well it's really so oh it does
sound like a good up well the thing is
it's just it brings random acts of
kindness Brian and and that makes
betting experience more and more
exciting is it you are rude no I'm just
looking down it's the way I'm my new
podcast style I'll just talk like they
love a little so say you want to back
Liverpool like I do but uh you just gone
the app uh I can place that also without
though yeah woke it up good she got it
good click the link in your description
yeah so say that you wanted to place a
bet on Liverpool to win so you go on
that on there with Liverpool 12 and you
buy expect or and then look you've also
got the option to undo it if you don't
want to do that but I'm totally sure
alright I'm not going to undo it
actually quite that's a good idea isn't
it and the odds have been quipped
to 9 to 10 she's pretty good yeah better
charitable love it they'll actually
quite certain it done so straight away
you know they've been quick to the earth
that's great so the
the link to quiz is in the description
check it out and see what boosted odds
you get it's good fun which it actually
just one can stop reading that no no and
worth a go
I've done it no for the last day of the
Premier League season I've already
groove it says it's always good fun and
you that's good fun I've actually
enjoyed that and you have to punt on the
final set of games which will be this
weekend come take a look
all right well while you're still
talking like that um download quest is
great
got some raspberries er yeah raspberries
my favourite fruit as far as I'll keep
them happy I've been mourning about the
lack of cacti so me tear some people be
in mourning lately about the table as
well for it bring back the old table it
will make for a better viewing
experience and once a that yeah I really
annoyed is that because I'm looking at
the common thinking John I think we kind
of get the old table to ever think that
there's a reason behind I would love to
use this pile of [__] but you ever think
that general I mean I'm doing me best if
he wants to curry from his house a
[__] table for me to [__] news
bring it just bring it in the words of
the rock very great fine you think that
was like what the rock was doing kind of
format is removal company ya just bring
us bring it hashtag just brittle rock
remove she would have done really well I
want to start off by talking about
guests MIT developments because we have
a rock we're getting you know everybody
to be that there are few people lost you
know saying well done on gas some people
complain in the Belkis do my best
yell regardless Italia you go approach
people
we're being lucky lately I feel like
we've done well lately Harry but you
know still it's not easy so I got people
seeing the same names everybody if you
if you still see in the same name every
week there's a good chance we can
already release them and they're either
on the way of comment of this said nor
the car maker or whatever the issue some
people who you wouldn't expect to say no
say no yeah pay or ignore you can frizzy
there was one person not noise so just
twice all right those one person a pawn
saw mmm who
just to be clear bigoted story she has
no qualms about taking a 12-inch dick in
her [__] but yet having second
thoughts about the podcast so I mean
either podcasting ye that's the kind of
show is we're
and me it's why do you think she would I
mean do you really want to come on
podcast not so any questions about it do
you think he's doing other shows hashey
she's a self-proclaimed attention seeker
so she's done Wow she's done lots of
other things why not why not crap on the
true Jordi's he needs all do you think
she thought it was maybe too highbrow I
don't know as I've seen some of this
she's very keen that I work I don't know
who you're talking about and I and you
will name her but I don't know who that
is
we'll leave it really but I mean because
she might come on yeah hope when were
together on so ok yeah everyone's been
sober while a porn star would give us
something a bit different we trying to
get Tommy Robinson just doesn't centre
he's one who's been suggested a fuckton
Tommy Robinson he's a real he's a poster
child for I don't quite know he's the
poster child for now but he's but he's
definitely opposed usage on him he's
opposed to child for entitled people
yeah I think he's a he's a big name I've
watched him on some other stuff where he
big main in question time the problem
I've got with getting someone like that
on the site you know in a way if you get
someone on the show it can't be seen
like you're backing this person yeah and
he has some sense um had done some
things in the past away I'm like you
know I just I wouldn't do that's gin and
I'm saying yeah
so lately he's putting a suit on and
he's going on shows and he's coming
across as quite educated blood to be
fair to him but then you know you look
back a few years ago he's got his
England shirt on and his David Beckham
sunglasses
you know bleach tips and his hair and
he's screaming all sorts of stuff to
foreigners and that and it's like I
don't know like it has he said that he's
not proud of those actions there's just
he's done so many things the password
for them on it's quite difficult I also
think it would be really unfair to bring
a guest on who said some stupid things
in the past maybe I'm snapchat or
wherever and question them about it for
almost two hours it would be really
unfair and make them talk about those
things that maybe they regret never I
mean it's also very productive to think
that he regrets it now nobody makes me
look great of those things yeah it's one
of those things that maybe maybe we will
go them on I would part me like so part
me thinks yeah let's get him on
thinks I want to talk to this guy I want
to hear what his views are I want to
know why so part of me is interested in
why he's so popular I think he says
things that a lot of people think not
what I need to get fresh [__] now but
he's obviously speaking for a quite a
big amount of people in Britain Toby
Robinson gyobu who are viewed as racist
because they don't like it people have
another race
he's obviously speaking against Islam
he's got a fundamental problem with
everything that's going on in it and
I've seen him have arguments with Muslim
people on shows and come across as quite
educated on the Quran and ie
he's obviously read it thoroughly you
think that means that he's right now no
not at all but what I'm saying is that
idiot who was in the England shirt years
ago David Beckham he looked like a
[__] [__] when he was going on like
that but what I'm saying is now he's
obviously trying to turn things around a
little bit simply crying lipstick he
gets taken more seriously he's trying to
get taken more seriously good luck for
that um yeah a lot of people say it I
mean I had a kid the other day I had a
fifteen year old I won't name him but he
messaged me on message meet you
Instagram somewhere yeah
anyway he messaged me and he said I
think you've what do you say I can find
the messages quite interesting he said
hello I said hi he said sup man how's
your white male guilt treating you I
said I don't know haven't had any lately
you said well maybe not recently anyway
this when it's the next podcast out like
I'm the Radio Times and I just want to
make it clear for everyone complaining
about iTunes Lawrence is in charge of oh
yeah yeah yeah bloom him he's I said
haha it's out on Thursday
you should really say essentially and in
that sense more you really neglect those
early highway sorts criticism I said
haha yeah I'm great he said SiC podcasts
you can't he said sorry mate seems
you're too big time to respond to the
appreciators I then said I imagine you
have to get all the little nuances well
I'm doing
I'm setting the scene of what is already
a bladder room was later the kids I
didn't know the kid at this so one week
it's all me you're promoting and
glamourizing drug use with a successful
poker player
the next you're condemning it with a
former addict you say you have a huge
audience of mostly impressionable kids
you might want to consider your actions
and what you're endorsing that's you
who's got us in those leading on in my
head but although we are a bunch of
[__] hypocrites to refer to these
Nilda so you think that having a so you
think talking about drugs he's
endorsement of drug see obviously he's
talking about [__] he's trying to get a
rise out of you
and clearly at work because those guys
15 minutes well named in there I mean
he'll have a little no one will ever
know who you are
you're watching this now no one gives a
[__] what your name is do you think you
endorse drugs I've never once said it is
good to take drugs so because of that no
do you think saying that you enjoyed
drug experiences is endorsement of drugs
i I saw I also come out and say it's
probably I love a good cheeseburger it
doesn't mean I think you should go out
and have a cheeseburger right this
second right the cheeseburgers are not
got Lucas easier to get into that
doesn't live unfortunately not obsolete
Joshua's getting all that Kush what was
quite funny was in this conversation and
I I sometimes act I'm just entertained
by it and he look he kept using the
phrase world of drugs and first of all
it made me think of like a DFS place
where you walk in and there's piles of
drugs and you go can I have some so we
heard we heard a poor cop we're on do
you think you endorsed entering as he
puts it the world of drugs as in the
world we all live in a world of drugs
well all I'm trying to put across here
is different stories from people who had
real lives and I'm trying to give them
you know the right questions to get get
that out there and if he happens to have
taken drugs before that's part of the
real world we're living in Duke to
ignore that and to pretend like it
doesn't exist is ingenuous it's [__]
and equally by having someone on like
Paul Hannaford we're also shown if you
do not take it in
and you do go off the deep end this is
exactly where you could end up
we're showing the pitfalls the dangers
if anything I think we've discouraged
more people from taking drugs than any
other podcast in the world in the last
two weeks it would depend so apart from
the anti-drugs podcast they really are
good at that
I learned anything I actually put
probably well if anything I actually is
probably an issue with that podcast in
that they're a bit too self-righteous um
I put it to you though sir that because
you have such a young impressionable
audience when you say hey I enjoy this
they all go because he messaged me and
he says after watching the podcast as a
poker player I felt like I was more
likely to take drugs this is such a dick
and I I thought they're thinking so what
me like I'm when I was 15 I mates took
drugs I mean I did a cautionary tale you
know the man who thought it was the Maz
bond threw himself out the window the
point that's exactly why psychedelics
might not be for you I put it to you
what if someone wants to be a masked man
if you want to be a mosebach then you
know got the Maz wealth luxury and see
what they could do for you because he
just saw to you as a mosebach I think it
wasn't actually amaz well which is why
he died and ultimately that's the answer
for us all really easily
yes boss Mo's bows now that is something
I definitely do endorse a bloody look
but I like a mars bar when it's been in
the fridge why don't like it when it's
all sitting at room temperature melted a
little bit I like it hard and cold a bit
like life yeah like you like your women
unfortunately hard and cold Italy
heartless yeah dead not dead I'm not did
you know that those people who are in
the necrophilia at school now I'm quite
aware of what most what that is yeah
yeah that's weird
or me are we really gonna go to Devon
this or there's nothing we will talk I'm
a just it's just more that you you
thought you looked a little bit
uncomfortable so I want to take it away
from though the fact that you are
ultimately respondent I generate long
until whatever I want to butt-fuck male
I was watching a TV show a while back
called Britain's darkest taboos yeah or
something along those I think was on
crime investigation they've been in
contact by the way
yes just saying the only contention
there was one young [__] horrible
little bastard who invited a girl round
who was just a friend and she went round
as a friendship it's a bit of a weird
guy
little did they that the family of the
girl know that he had a daughter now in
the next you know he was really into
gruesome [__] and he killed her and then
he proceeded to take photographs of him
having sex with her body in every room
of the house and that and it's like that
really [__] me up when I was watching
it because I wish to do with this well
I'm healing in them [__] necrophilia
I guess is what a fulsome to point out a
really quite a mild commented to boo in
it yeah I mean actually that's one was
called it's a taboo to sort of you know
smoke indoors I mean it's a [__]
[__] dead body we had a very website
wandering a [__] of your sisters and
it's not really the same no [__] a
dead girl yeah well anyways watch the
boom Oh sort of
he don't debated again in the living
room that the family I'm gonna see this
podcast hopefully this anyway that to me
face being on a show is trivializes it
really did trivialize it all because I
was watching it in on the intro it like
has blood triple and down and I'm like
imagine you're the family watching this
documentary buck and the blood
Strickland it's like can we just make it
a little bit more prefer clinical
professional yeah you know it what can
we have a bit more professionalism
please on date but I was it channel so
yeah see I crime investigation but it's
the one brilliant I've kind of I love
that shuttles
I can tell white people and I'll put it
that white people love crime rates they
love watching shows that crime we do why
what look at Netflix I just find we have
cried not not crime I find difference in
less than I like solid if I was to just
and invite any old random fun on this
show got people to be like yeah the
guests have dropped right off other than
that yeah the destroy in criticizing us
yeah and now in any way that's a crime
against entertainment
but yeah so at what other to be doing it
was like it's not women who kill sort of
sale [__] you know when there was one
guy who had got the his wife yeah maybe
in the car they'd been on holiday and
she'd said on the holiday that's it it's
all that he was a [__] nut job
clearly so they're driving on the way
home and there's like footage from the
motorway and you just see the court VR
off the motorway like 70 miles an hour
so they're basically I genuinely think
at this point sorry you've gotten the
wrong title of the show yeah I mean he's
got to be Brittany's dog mr. boom now
again is not a taboo to drivers haven't
emailed managers veer off the motor car
I'm not a palooka watch it blue I took
in I just don't call that a swirly
okay no one thinks that [__] a corpse
either to do I'm gonna google it what
[Music]
[__] call me Ilana is very funny that
you think only reason I haven't told
them that either I'm not very well so
you are all the sizin and unwell mum
obvious mentally I'm f---ing they could
get them in the comments tell them in
the comments tell em shoot em tell them
our left wing is and whether it matches
left-wing values I mean the fact is it
matches my left-wing values did you
daughters to boom if you want you could
go to a doctor for free because you're
on the NHS these are the episodes I I
just want to read some of the not to be
but this is this is killing someone not
to pick this is these are the episode
guide to booby sort of you know taking a
taking [__] in public as to be that was
yeah taboo or [__] a girl's [__]
until she shits that would be a taboo
I say that's that's definitely a sexual
to be yeah but that's also sort of as
some of the episode words are our Father
killed our mother not her to be my
stepfather took my sister as a lover not
that to be damnit to be one not to do
that is the case the question right
we've done we've done that no news so
yeah what a big to do I would fancy
being a presenter on chroma
I'd love to do like my own sort of
search into crimes
Ruth left me and you gone yeah look over
unsolved crimes mysteries and you ever
worry that if you do on solve crimes
that you're going to dig something up
that maybe that music Act I now do you
ever worry that if you're doing that you
you and Fred and Lou are some things or
wonder we're like looking for the
missing children and they're underneath
the pot view and it just so happens that
some reason the evidence leads back to
your house such [__] mother did the
other one like if they work for crime
investigation norther dinar okay there
were two presenters who get a podcast at
the digestives just the Builder or
something a lot of the board is jobless
what are to do and so ok oh you mean a
lot of this when I can live it is more
the use of the word to be making lousy
really could have retitled the show
after yes like maybe killing others
killing other young people
hashtag taboo white people watch this
why people watch it you know what you
know I love I saw a show I saw a poster
from just for the second world war maybe
it's just after the Second World War
familiar worth allows and so to do
manage that they they have archives II
museum smoking I love a museum
Louisville in Louisville and it just
said it was good like nowadays it's like
you know considering you know blah blah
blah the pro sport just went by rice and
I thought yeah it's good advertising
isn't it right now it's like you know
what are you thinking maybe you should
consider the new iPhone 7 but in the
past it's just like you know get soap in
a very straight of the poem yeah maybe
we should do that like just download
podcasts and just have it as called but
some people and I supposed I guess sort
of like that isn't it bug you loaded to
me no I mean hashtag notch I can I think
yeah good guy so that is it to be um
what goes on in those locker rooms is
definitely a food yet but not we're not
going to talk about that yes but so um
you enjoy watching shows where people
kill people
I like a documentary type [__] I also
like disappeared which is a show about
people who disappear and then on some
episodes then find them and then
thomna dawned and he always left I like
the ones where they never find them more
because I'm always left wondering like
wonder what happened
I wonder where hey like a mystery I love
trying to solve mystery like why are
certain youtubers getting so many views
I'll never know but also where I've
other youtubers he's gone and hidden
yeah you know imagine if we did that as
a parody where we were so privileged
effect man's this man's views disappear
a big [__] magnifying glass so one day
all my views they just disappeared
it's as if amendment conclusion
documentary is you just boring
and then he veers off the motorway from
tomorrow I've actually got them Roma
Totenberg guests from that criminal
short I recently got Tyson Fury's phone
number Wow
maybe I could give more ring yeah I mean
he'd probably be good at making people
disappear bring him up
and what what would you say to Tyson
how'd the phone call go hello Tosun met
sir
how'd you get his number the front stop
calling I'm a heavyweight champion of
the world lovely big other new myth so
you probably want to listen given you're
bigger than him now he's six foot six
that you're wound up recently as well
the 26th on how hard you know to get to
refer in my heaviest I was about 25 and
a half for that was pure muscle
well that wasn't it wasn't it was bulk
was I involved what percentage muscle
quite heavy though a lot of muscle it
was quite a lot of muscle that yells I
was still fat I'm still [__] so do you
think you endorsed drugs no do you think
I endorse drugs either going to endorse
alcohol of a bit that's a bit much
though is it there was a study the other
day that said that radio 2 in England
which like a BBC mainstreamed ization
endorsed casual drinking too much so and
so presenters ago I was in the pub the
other night a bit too much and so we'd
like normalize it and they put bait now
that's what I thought was a bit weird
they said that was encouraging people
don't drink in the poem [__] sick of
what a [__] piece so society relevant
it's a [__] chalky not drink in the
pub anymore gentlemen normal guys just
not have a drink there are these two
straight guys just having a drink it's
often the way darling to you sir
obsession
where the [__] was this podcast gun I've
got no idea I think you worried if we
don't talk about sex drugs rock and roll
gang rape then we we lose the viewers
let's not at all I'm just I'm a bit ill
and I'm wondering what the [__] am I
talking about do you know when you have
a moment where you're halfway through
the conversation you're like one might
even say yeah many many times
yeah all the time another after you've
been smoking drugs yet I don't smoke
drugs can't smoke mushrooms anyway um I
don't
and I wouldn't endorse it either so what
I was supposed to say something I
absolutely don't endorse drugs and I
think they're bad idea if you're under
any age don't do drugs
what do you think some drugs should be
legalized yes which one's the ones the
psychedelics possibly but mainly are
you've gotten legalized weed as a joke
something I'm sick the death of haven't
they meet that guy behind the shops it's
doing me head and I just want to go into
the shops and buy it yeah it took me
talks and it's thought the NHS with it
so long and with I mean a [__] takes
ages as well and then now this should
legalize weed it's harmless compared to
I do in the gateway drug is what a lot
of people say alright fair enough but a
gateway into the world of drugs but
alcohol is a gateway in the world of
alcoholism like it you know Heath babies
are a gateway networ the factory in a
[__] if you extremists will be
extremists it doesn't matter whether
they're really anything at weed alcohol
cigarettes the food whatever they're
into experiments will just [__]
douche it to the extreme what do you
think you are addicted to my arm I am
quite a classic extremist in many ways
so but I always I don't take things to
the extent other people do so I take
things just far enough that I can live a
life where I come across as normal but
the whole time behind the scenes yes I
see I'm I'm doing everything as much as
I possibly can Wow such that's such a
sort of weird quote that could get taken
out of context anywhere really if you
can find it seems I'm
doing anything as much as I possibly can
what are the good thing is I've really
been so vague that plausible deniability
I could be anything could mean anything
but it means everything
do you enjoy everything I am I literally
so I if you look at life like a across
that's being so in in the top you know
and you just pull out and it's dripping
wet I am just ringing that [__] cloth
right I would get as much out of life as
possible me well sometimes if one day I
want to make this quite [__] clear
because I might never reach an age where
I can do an autobiography yes if one day
I [__] die just know that everything
you think I was probably doing I was
doing way more than that right if you do
get too caught you weren't doing it and
I'm reasonably ma'am
no not at all not at all within the
limits as I say I push everything to the
limit so where I can still operate at a
fully compos mentis level right there
I'm still able to drive I'm still able
but within the boundaries of what is
respectable so what I'm saying to you is
I endorse and join life you know I don't
and draws drugs yes and also me it must
be going crazy listening to this maybe
it was funny was he was a rough bastard
he then said get Tommy Robinson on the
podcast so yeah see he also had me clips
in the podcast and he said it was very
responsible what the way you act the way
I uh Wow both of us he donated [__] a
pole you don't have to watch it's true
that's the ultimate capo I know it is
but really it we're here like you don't
watch your channel DRA be there it's
true I mean if your liking and don't
turn it on yeah I know it's a cop-out so
I admit it's a cover but I think I I'm a
I'm a little irresponsible in the sense
that I probably adore stringing too much
I'll probably swear a bit too much what
about sex
do I think how real I am rewards younger
people and I don't need all [__] them
the way other people do I feel like they
could email me in and say a mother in
this problem Georgie I'm having that
problem Jordy and I will literally
you talk to them yeah on a lake of nut I
talk to them like I talk to my best
friend so as far as happen saying I
might not be mr. perfect but out of all
the youtubers I connect a lot with me
audience I'm always trying to help and I
give them a real solid advice so I may
not be perfect but I am the best that's
what I'm saying right so the best
youtuber in the world okay when you get
sick do you stop what do you do when you
get sick I push through it under Smith
I'm not in a position right now where I
can get I can give meself break that I
can take breaks I'm a [__] slave to
them but I'm doing really to be under
something laughing I love most of what
we like what we make I do the only thing
I find a pain in the arse is the
football hung over some MCA this times
where I don't want to have to watch all
of that football I just want to make the
video but in order to do a video like
that you have to really semi I know what
you're talking about you know that's
what you've definitely talked about he
went me where you've got to know you've
got to watch all the football girls talk
about it yeah it's a [__] on so MEMS I
haven't got time but I have two to one
people are like well why's the hugging
over a deal it let's hope I just hadn't
watched all those much as I just watched
Newcastle instead doing that you needed
time to watch PSG round Madrid but it's
similar honest I should call other the
teams in the bottom off the league more
but at this point in the season unless
you're getting relegated are you getting
top four no one gives a [__] yeah I did
find we boot them
you sort went semi viral in the Spurs
world didn't you I thought was weird
wasn't it the thing is I in a 15 minute
video you know you get a lot of bang for
your buck on my show yeah definitely
memory but this first time love what you
say because you basically qualified why
they wear bottle job well I back them up
a little bit because I look at them now
and I think I've sucked and loved
Newcastle to be in their position
they've grown a team from a young lad
like Harry Kane who supposes like
they're sheera back in the day they've
brought their lollies in the Newcastle
were interested
bottled it Ericsson Newcastle resident
bottled it they got them for about 17
million I don't need to paid that much
force on all right lamella was quite
expensive for here- each other's much
this season now Whateley in Dyer and
Claire said that they've got a good
spine I just I look at them and I think
with the money that money lated a mud
city spent with a squad Chelsea of got
you would have thought that those
probably would have been the three super
powers this season yeah maybe Arsenal
maybe them for I think Spears was the
least pressure on the mo of everyone to
perform so for them to get second and
finished so far ahead of money mated and
city in terms of points Harlem back
really I've done here that disburse
funds him yeah this didn't seem to get
by Enders a little bit you know did they
liked it yeah some of them said I don't
normally watch this guy but I like what
he says here how many people do you
think saying about you I don't know what
is funny is because we talked to
Schaefer the other day a lot about
Facebook so I thought you know as I'm
going to get Facebook a little bit over
girl and put some videos out on Facebook
see what the response is and why we talk
about how different the audience says on
Facebook and the first response was of
one guys in or this guy's buck again is
he obviously he'd like the page he
doesn't pay attention to YouTube so he's
obviously made as orders aside Facebook
ticking that when he doesn't watch me I
dysentery is and I don't exist on a ho
have been there grinding a fair old
audience yeah unless you think maybe he
was just typing your thoughts like
Facebook does sort of say what are you
thinking every time I don't if it still
does I don't believe me to know that
[__] little caucus token three honest
I don't think I banned him from the
channel for that and locked him and you
blocked it get off get like a lot of
people on are on on Facebook I tend a
block more than any records I just I
just you get more conce on Facebook
she's tend to be decades downing no you
just yeah because like I say people
click on my video on YouTube because
they want to say that video on Facebook
it will happen to appear on people's
feeds who don't want to see me yeah so
they do get more of your space Utley and
I just can't be also that said I mean I
don't give a [__] really know
I think some people are too friendly on
Facebook like that sort of like our
don't worry about it it's all engagement
is what they go I'm not that cut I'm not
that guy I want quality people watching
ideally I feel like on YouTube we've got
a really good audience do you think
quality people are people who agree with
you know I want to see if you criticize
me that's fine but just make it
constructive like not can you get a
better table you know that case you're
blocking when I've made a one and a half
hour podcast with someone like Paul had
a fight and we're talking about heroin
use his garner life Hales turned over a
new leaf what he wants to do in the
future I was trying to help people and
you're commenting on the [__] table
mayor that's just a waste of your [__]
like I look at that comment think I've
traveled all the way down to [__]
London I'm here I've managed to arrange
someone great like for halal we've gone
through all of that I've come home we've
added it we've got out on the channel
and your comment that's like the [__]
table I mean I'm like whatever I mean I
know the table [__] right it's fine the
table [__] table' [__] but there's a lot
more going on in this video than the
[__] table
no that's but the table gets in the way
you've entered the world of tables the
energy of an under grunt didn't lose his
leg for you to comment on a [__]
table mate just soon alright
or did he definitely enough of the table
what do you think people like so because
that's heart that is actually the army
does preserve our right to be able to
say whatever we want
yeah look I mean that is true but I also
reserve the right to bond someone for a
dick Mohammed look good point I mean
yeah you're allowed to do it both ways
right do you think have you ever worried
that I mean I find it weird I get a lot
of people asking me going ketta Brian to
unblock me please
I think people misunderstood who I was
back in the day so they when I was doing
the runs and that I the ban when you'll
run and you get a certain kind of image
and I really didn't like that after a
while I realized I just looked like a
[__] [__] because when you're in
the in the heat of the moment after a
match that's who you kind of are all
football fans get a bit like that you
know if you have you really bitter about
losing a game anyway
so that's why I give me such a day or
two before I make a video now after the
match because I can see the funny side
of things a little bit more and I don't
like making run videos because it draws
so much negativity so I'd rather other
channels do that if you stripped away
everything about you and you just left
the core board unit will be there
Who am I as a person as a youtuber what
do you mean as a person ah everything
everything is superfluous what you know
she took it all are you looking for a
word to describe her so I know sort of a
summary what do you think it would be in
there what like what's in the middle of
that cream egg that is Brian that's a
hell of a [__] question where the
Thanks I don't know what you're asking
for here though really I'm asking you if
you do you think there's anything which
which is permanent like you know was
always pre decided about you what do you
think everything is human nature what is
it in mind you have a nature I've
definitely got a nature really yeah I
remember things about me before anything
happened to me in my life which were
very much the person I am sitting right
in front of you know was in there at
four years or five isn't he think that
sort of presumptive so he just you know
you were told at that age that's where
you are assets when I turned out this
was this was in me from day one
I hope so I think in this maybe you sort
of liked I one thing I feel like I've
gone on throughout my entire whole life
was underestimated but if there's a word
that sums me of my life up is
underestimate even any baby he currently
underestimated baby Kenny but by by
certain people what I would eventually
turn out to be I think because of the
way my dad was I think a lot of people
just say is just going to grow up to be
they that you think people might why
because my dad was a [__] maniac to
be honest of this so I want to end on me
from a young age
of RIT is going to grow up to be like
that but yeah people underestimate it
even now even now so I was pigeon-holed
on youtubers the rant guy and then even
though I've broken out with that there
are still some people who still think
I'm that guy because they have them
there on face with haven't seen this in
two years or whatever but even now I did
that gym video now you know you were had
nothing to do with that gym video until
the very anyone attached it but what I'm
saying is because it's so different any
content I've done now you've taught me a
lot and a lot of those lessons I've
learned and I'm saying from directing
when we went to do the holidays before
when you were talking about all right
where we're going to get the best shot
and all of these things that I've sat
and watched and learned I'm a quick
learner so I like the thing anyway and
I've took a lot of that on board and I
went I've got me made to shoot the gym
video and I said stand here stand they
do this do that did it we got all the
footage together
I picked the music I chose the words and
I did everything and at the end I asked
you to make the music dip when I'm
talking
that was that was all I wanted from here
and to help us with the color because it
looked a bit too green
on that video we've got a comment the
top comment on that videos is this has
Laurence written all over it Laurence
did this video because it's too good for
me to admit and that just sums up my
[__] life it is maybe people going
this has Laurence although not just even
as a young kid like people met so pretty
cuz I was a really big strong lad young
must be thick yeah so I've just had that
from day one pretty much if you can't be
more than one thing I don't know big
strong people they tend to be a bit a
bit slow I guess I just got totally
pigeonhole dinner and do you ever feel
like you pigeonhole other people I think
everyone kind of does that a little bit
so like if if a woman is it looks a
certain where you might sort of sort of
thing well I've met 10 other girls who
look like you and they're a bit like
that so therefore you're probably like
that as well
it's a bit of a weird thing isn't it
what people wear the way they present
themselves do you think you know if you
change up what you wore people see you
differently maybe if I talk differently
I mean like that Bry Bry Bryce classic
I love like if that if that was the
first video of mine you ever seen you'd
be like what the actual what am i
watching yeah yeah it's also interesting
rubberized his other character that so
what how would you describe Barbara when
the briber I come from if I acted the
exact opposite of what I really are
that's bro bro I think I think it'll be
different I think is what you and he's a
lot of what you've observed
oh yeah as well I also think it's a
little bit of what you like about those
people as well I think you quite like
Rai by I like the innocence of what a
clouded view of the world they've got so
when you come from a world where see
Bonnie a parent has been locked in
prison before you've seen like real
reality of people getting the [__]
kicked out of them like on a stay
tonight yeah I grew up on account
services so eating my rabbis backhanding
and then you see these up Market middle
class upper class vloggers who've just
they haven't grown up and I'm not saying
they don't know sadness because they
they might know stuff that I don't have
any clue but we gave what the persona on
the videos of everything so great and
everything's so fun all the time
what are ignorant that they put across
I just part of it pisses me off a part
of it makes me laugh so I just play poke
fun and it's so sorry you've easy in my
naive so that's why on the video you
gets cut fish because he's so naive yeah
and he's oblivious to it at the end why
do you think there is so like do you
think it's a bad thing that these people
are so um no I don't know are they naive
I mean that I think they're definitely
know if you look at alfea the classic
case right alfie is making so much money
for putting out such average basic
videos but he knows them you cannot
really log if you're getting rewarded
for being absolutely mediocre and you're
getting rewarded as he's ripping the
rewards of what healing to kids he's
ripping the rewards of what the best
youtuber in the world should be getting
the level of money he's on
should be because he saw brand brandable
and he's written the words of the best
Cullen personally but he isn't the best
talent he is absolutely mediocre so in
every other place if you look at
football ex footballers unless to go to
China the best footballers messi ronaldo
are getting the most money in the movies
you could argue the best up let's get
the most money
well alright maybe aren't any hopkins
and people like buying guns don't get
what they should get but you're not i'm
saying in youtube on social media
because it's still so young i feel like
a lot of the people out there who were
rippin the biggest rewards on the best
they're the people who got there first
or kneeled down a market quickest and
i'm sitting the hour late of the party
again this is laughable this is a link
did you give him mean it that's what i
sort of surprises me that how frustrated
you get about it because i always think
of you as a realist or sort of someone
who likes to say things how they are and
the way I read that situation is so he
has exploited that market not in a bad
way but he's found a USP and he's done
it and he's got it well I give him
credit for that
yeah I'm not angry about that right so
again what you want great I'm not angry
at all I make a fun of it I make it I
find it amusing yeah but what I am
saying is I hope in 10 years time when
YouTube has developed into a place where
it's survival of the fittest and not
survival of the shittest now we're going
to get people rewarded for great con now
and not for but survival of the face is
a subjective thing because you can be
fit and be quick or you can be fit and
be strong and some people would argue
you can be or you could also be fit and
be clever right some people would argue
he's surviving because he's a clad he's
he's the shrewdest all right so I think
you're giving him way too much credit I
think he's he's making the kind of
content he is capable of making and he's
he's maxing out on the god-given gifts
that he's being given god-given and more
we're already what already gift you need
to be et we're always going to have the
kids friendly [__] alright and that's
good and I think we need that final wolf
but what I'm saying is ultimately I
want to see create youtubers be rewarded
and not just people who've got friends
who are great youtubers yeah that is a
little bit I mean you do get that
feeling there's an element of nepotism
there but then I also sort of worried
because I don't know I mean I think
before you become a parent and I'm
obviously not a parent before you come
up become a parent you think I want my
kids have a realistic view of the world
but you also want you kids to be happy
now he makes people's kids happy yeah
but he's not giving them a realistic
view of the world is it just basically
kids TV but on YouTube I think a lot of
it is that right now yeah I was talking
to a ideally driver yesterday from
Sierra Leone Addison Lee he's like a
London taxi coming from Sierra Leone and
he's come over this country he's got his
son and his tellers always sewn on that
and he goes on me suddenly so much as
YouTube because yes is what I did matter
he likes the f2 and I was like you know
great luck I like f1 make thanks yeah
you're good with the f2 you but yes it's
like what kind of stuff do you do and I
sort of I said you know there's nothing
I won't talk about and we have young
allowed us you know messaging in about
lose my virginity and [__] like that and
as I asked that's [__] great I would
have no problem and he had seen the
content this point nobody is like I'd
have no problem in my son watching that
and I thought yeah but some people would
so a lot of people would generally find
that a bit unusual like you know I I
don't understand why people honor I'm at
the Paul Hannaford school of thought oh
geez of don't hide reality from your
kids that is what's reality reality is
what is going on out there like what's
going on people haven't [__] sex
people are taking drugs people are
[__] people by being violent shit's
happening
general Taylor I've lived there so you
know how would you what age you should
tell a kid about those things I think
the best way to do that with children is
to spoon-feed them as they get older
more and more and more infirmary I so
you obviously you give them a very brief
and small explanation of how the world
can be frying these different factors
and the bad parts of life in the good
parts of life and I'll take it older
because the more give them more and
their brains will adapt to it like but
to tell them nothing and then when they
turn 11 go well I'll tell you what
people will be huh
you know the stock is [__] you know
the birds and the bees it's [__]
they're having sex and sex is where Mark
cops is knob up a woman not that we need
about our Sicily wait what
of what that is there's sin up a woman
she knows it but that's the way it was
explained of when you go into this room
they put a video on to something to me
and you come out the room gone well [__]
me I never expect that now you don't
think no me at the time you know [__]
anything obviously that wasn't the case
for me because I had prior knowledge but
you you'd lost even NZ not some people
but the that's the way they let the kids
find out if yeah I was found a little
bit weird school baby do we I knew from
quite young age what sex was but it was
never it made it less of a big deal like
you know when you sort of you know when
feeling because I remember once into a
girl lets us say like a copper to you
how are you I must have been about
[__] 10 and I must I think I'd say in
like a movie where it happens or some
amount and and she was like well what do
we do and I was I don't know yeah
I'm you said only right what do we big
smooth yeah eat me eat me off and do you
what did you do g kisser
I guess though yeah yeah I was kissing
girls from about seven years old like
we'd hide under a courts and that and
like behind the school and have a kiss
and all that and I loved it but not with
tons not no no no he's nothing that the
first tongue kiss came a lot for the way
a 2009 yeah yeah I had no [__] clue
what I was doing but I just liked the
little I was when I was seven I was just
a little Peck in it it was like innocent
yeah you're a bit like why why is there
I was like all the [__] butterfly
feelings and all sorts of [__] going on
and so you know why you're doing at that
point
I shall status of kissing a girl I was a
I fancied girls in the most innocent way
you can imagine so it was like
just pray children I mean it was just
pretty what you'd want a seven-year-old
boy everything and really nothing yeah
to know them says no malice no just just
the thing that were pretty no clue what
was going on we need that change God I'd
have to say 11 12 13 11 so different it
went from nortis 7/32 sexuality in it
once when when I started noticing girls
were growing boobs I was like what the
[__] are they mmm interested interested
I'm the most girl in the school
to grow boobs like she was dog ruff god
bless her every boy goes it was like she
instantly became an 8 or 9 or 10 just
overnight it was like every boy was
overlooked in the dog face and like what
are tits are muscles doing massive at
all New England boy
breasts are breasts so the fact that she
had them and no other girl did made her
instantly stand oh yeah she must have
gotten so much [__] referred or parents
must be worried about that I've never
thought about it like that but now was a
grown man like yeah you think if I had a
daughter and she was like 12 13 but she
had like big boobs and I'd be like oh
[__] hell I would feel until it but
this this is the thing you've wrapped
them up we parents don't talk to the
kids enough I think that they're
terrified to have a conversation with a
chemistry that way again what they're
here is too much for them do you think
that's why a lot of kids do come and
watch YouTube like I think people see is
that the father figures and all I care
I've had big brother sort of [__] before
like goal or something like that you
know like because parents are terrified
of having awkward uncomfortable moments
which I just find so weird like I don't
know I've never really had that in my
family I could say anything I want your
what the old man was a sex health advice
other wasn't she Larry land is so
different like so she's used to that
shirt yeah and I guess the rest of my
family were as well like they're just
very open about sex you know both side
so so not just one it's already close
ever come to me and say like you know
I'm worried about this I'm prematurely
ejaculating or I would be so if your son
come see and say dad I'm prematurely
ejaculating
I mean there's an issue nobody saying
for example that's not ever happened to
me I would be so chilled out about it
like I just think people notice I your
old man
people are so frightened but the thing
is I denying these conversations and by
putting up these barriers what you're
doing is given the kids problems later
on down the road because when they could
have had these conversations in known
oh god this is normal or this isn't
normal or whatever the left in a
situation of the unknown and that is the
most scary thing of the [__] law I do
find a lot of find it weird when people
do talk about normally not normal I know
you mean by that but it's like really if
you pass things like that you sort of
end up she has a [__] thing you talk
about normal and not normal who was a
tip not only a couple I don't know them
personally but I know of them they're a
friend of a friend bring bring the kid
back the the woman had been struggling
to give birth for get pregnant rather
for ages finally gets plenty and gives
gives birth to a boy again a little boy
human a a little boy got it cat a little
boy anyway I think was a little boy
anyway the fig will figure it out and
anyway it weeks later they go back in
for tests and whatever and they said it
wasn't a little boy together girl and
apparently the band's genitalia had been
so the vagina being on inside-out so it
appeared like a pianist to start off
with hi but there was no testicles and
it was big so she's going to need a
gender requirement or whatever whatever
surgery they're going to give her but it
just blew my [__] mind like because
the I feel like I know pretty much
everything that is there is about the
just regular life like I thought I saw
it heard it all known I was like [__] me
and inside out vagina I was [__]
insane couldn't believe it no I'm sure
not do you you [__] painting the
bedroom blue yes that's my boys
yeah oh my god now I got to change
everything pink because there's no way
this girl could like blue no but of
they named a boy's name and eyelets and
now they've got it let's have this
Alex's name it actually was a on a name
that could go both ways yay
but they still decided to rename it Ryan
Ryan Etta Briana Briana Lawrence could
be a female and much of that yeah but I
mean that must be quite shocking as a
parent it would frighten the [__] but
at least it happens early on though when
you don't know when the kid doesn't
really know you know so it's not like it
they're like nine and they go by the way
us a vagina and you're like so what hmm
well that's a very understanding because
I've watched a few programs where kids
are sayin to the parents I'm not a girl
I'm a boy I was quite trendy for a while
did you watch Sony's documentaries about
like fascinating I mean gender is an
interesting one some people get quite
angry about it you know I'll admit don't
assume my agenda is one of those [__]
hashtags these days no no I mean some so
some people get angry about the gender
side of things being given agenda some
people also get angry that some people
don't like to class people by gender I
remember when I went to university
someone didn't want me to refer to them
as him or her they just wanted to use
the name our all go to phrase them why
because they didn't because they felt it
the language was it was it was it a man
or a woman or biologically I mean if
you're going to class them now I think
you'd say they you did another dick or a
funny I never saw no but what would you
have assumed I would have assumed is a
woman right yeah but well she sort of
was she middle for diddle or did she
dress more like masculine or feminine um
I think there was a group of people who
didn't want to be classed as god it's so
trendy asthma I'm glad when you tell us
[__] like this on like [__] glad I
didn't go in the university no I think I
went to a very sort of very specific
university that did sort of encourage
people to think that way and sort of you
know hopefully they've grown up no oh
you see that's the thing so and I would
annoy them why is that immature its aw
this is going to be pissing some people
I've sudden give me here is on a man or
woman is often a oh it's so cliche I've
gone to uni a lot a few spliffs
dad's paying me [__] rent money and
guess what you're
going to assume my gender [__]
typical but watching your legs right
let's have it out let's have a look at
it no I'm not gonna no be so while I
show it to you so what exactly don't do
that so what's the problem with that my
problem yes I just get bored of the
whole cliche or you will not assume so
it's we got problems in the world the
fact that you think people give a [__]
what you are you don't you're valuing
yourself too much pet one name I feel I
don't think those people are saying and
yeah I'm not tricking themselves far too
seriously when they start saying you're
not allowed to see him or her to me cuz
I'm special you're not special you're
not that special
I don't all being given I don't think
I've ever said a [__] about to make your
mind of what you've got and then let one
or choose your D quotes
um I don't think they're saying I'm
special they are they are event I asking
for separate treatment or what every
[__] else gets across the world there
are people no separate treatment no
they're just saying let's change the way
that people act do you know what no but
what what they're doing is they're
worrying too much of a trivial [__] like
like the gender of themselves yeah the
fact that it's already been decided me
it doesn't matter whether I hear him or
her the [__] feller upstairs as what
a dick between your legs or you're an
atheist what are you saying I'm not a
full glorious I'm agnostic I'm a
full-blown atheist a while I'm sorry but
you're not gay going on but the bottom
line is biologically speaking you either
have occurred or a [__] and if there's
nothing there then let us know and they
will have a look at the claim you're a
medical miracle so then what would you
do if they didn't have anything well
we're gonna have to take it out the side
and Slaven we'll find out what's going
on and then what would you climb would
you call them him or her in the event
that there is no such thing biologically
a mastermind or the ceiling you work on
I think we might have an alien on my
hands I'll say alien so Lillian now that
now the issue with that is and I know
pointed forward to interest you in sort
of wine job a little bit do you think I
mean do you think then in that instance
do you see anything wrong with what you
said maybe I'm being a little bit
insensitive fair enough but what I'm
saying is right now there is real issues
going on the world people are getting
bombs dropped on there people are
starving we can't afford to feel there
are
homeless people nobody cares that much
if you've got a [__] or a [__] just let
one know and we'll say can you take him
over there to the toilet I heard over
the toilet whatever it's not a big deal
the fact that I could have change my
behavior to suit your beliefs not not
doing it but then what if they weren't
it so then what if they said to you the
fact that they have to change their
behavior to suit your belief on Iran or
the dawn but they do so why are I can
attack the way that you want them to act
not I'm not I you are I am acting the
way everyone I'm imagining you right now
no military to see him or her that's
fine I find an illusion or like but then
you don't have to talk to me you can
remove yourself away from it again
that's a cop-out it is at all cost so
what but then so what so then what
you're saying is and this what I find
funny about you is you talk about
conspiracies and you talk about
supporting people who may be on the
mainstream but then when they have their
own issues with the structure you say
then they think they're special so I
don't quite get what you have a problem
with them but not a problem with people
if a man in tonight's your question the
structure of society so these people are
doing that right over you should
question the structure of society by all
means if you think that it's unfair that
there are problems real problems such a
real present poverty such as people not
having food these things what racism but
when you talk about not being called him
or her I'm not being funny me it's far
from dropping like the f-bomb or the N
bomb I'm not degrading you by calling
you him or her I am just simply calling
you what biologically you are I think a
lot of people do though gets like so
this is what's quite weird about it is
actually those people didn't get as
upset maybe as some of the people who
maybe agree with you get upset about
gender I've seen some of the month the
PM themselves up into this bloody they
just look so we had a mattifying crack
on you make yourself look however you
want to look yet but don't force me to
see him just just I don't even care to
not just crack on I'll call you whatever
you whatever you want let's crack on but
in my own lane if I'm referring to you
in common
tuition I also her mother they went to
the toilet but you think that shows a
lack of respect for what they believe
what does he believe will they believe
they are doing as men and women no they
were all just spirits I don't think
that's what they say well what are the
sin you sound a bit like prison planet
what are they sir no I think what
they're saying is that the referring to
gender like that puts a lot of
importance on it important do you think
I'm not I think by making the other poet
is what puts important summers but
you're the one who's saying who's
disagreeing they're asking something
quite basic and simple do you think from
Italy all these arguing a third thing I
mean it's a pain in the arse see you're
famous my enemy I'll see you you nation
have to do it you should enough today
I'm saying that it isn't a big deal what
you are why should I have to change my
behavior to suit you do you do you think
there are only ticket if you want to
refer to yourself as the third thing X
you know the thing in the middle fine
you can do that I've got no problem with
that
dress yourself up as whatever me it's
whatever people can crack on but don't
expect you take heart Joe I'm not
getting involved but you are I'm not I'm
not involved with them so do you believe
gender is man or do you think it's only
that well I know that there are some
scientific exceptions one in a million
might come up with both hermaphrodite
stuff like that
fair enough channel I'm in but watch it
what would you like what I don't know
what the [__] we call them what after
night or maybe I don't know I think
that's much probably in an old way of
saying I'm trying to be a [__]
essentially ignorant just yet
I just don't know that I love the
Wikipedia lot yeah and so do you think
people that they're referred to as
progressives do you think that why there
was a progressive about brother Vogler
because they're seen as bit and I think
that's wrong because it's not
necessarily progressives it's a sideways
stuff it's with Nick time
spending time on [__] that's pretty
irrelevant whether it's a man/woman
export why very often you say politics
is irrelevant I want you to know the
rhetoric I want it caller tix to be I
want anytime that we're using as a group
of people to be spent on important
issues education you know health think
why the heart of Education is saying
people an education is part science and
Elyse you're making jobs further massive
jumps what's that worth a jump so
education is is knowledge right what if
you're part of that knowledge is
learning about mother uncle I we can
learn about those beliefs so for example
there may be someone out there who
thinks that aliens landed on the moon
last week and now they're headed for the
planet Earth channel said I can do
whatever you want say what everyone but
don't make me believe it don't make me
get involved let me kind of make you
involved I think that the only way to be
fair in this world is for you do your
thing I do my thing what if those two
things a by like they are binaural e
different so it's a very cool they go
completely against each other what what
you do then is I say I'll tell you can
do your thing and I'll do my thing but
what you can call yourself
gender X and I can call you him fine
what if in a respectful society they
what if they become the majority and you
begin to lose out because of that would
you have a problem with that I'm already
losing that we lose another alladhi so
do you think in the future then that
they will if they become the majority of
the beliefs then you begin to lose out
I'll be long dead before those [__]
go that your cable your kids could still
be here or a next generation of your
family and I'll be dead on the ground
and on my headstone is going to be I'm
not [__] calling them a more her I'm
calling mammy it's him or her right dot
yeah on the headstone and it'll be very
eroded
now I've got no problem with what they
want I just don't get me involved with
it please it's ridiculous that's what I
find funny so something
we'll get very passionate about some
things that and they say they don't get
involved with other things what do you
think you feel passionate about I think
what I think we should as a society to
be passionate about things that really
can help people in a in a big way
heritage I think that the fact that the
poverty is what it is there's food banks
or all these issues let's spend time on
what really matters and what can change
lives me calling someone Oh Tim her ex
whatever isn't going to change anyone's
life really it's going to make them feel
better for two seconds let's talk about
issues that make people ugly honestly
think a ferret you're going to be a live
do you honestly think those people are
asking you to call them not him or her
because it makes them feel better oh
it's all about them it's all about ego
without though key things you think is
ironic that you just said there are some
people I'll tell you what just give us a
second at all I think there might be
some people out there who don't know
what they are and that's where it upsets
them emotionally and the damn people
I [__] empathize with that because
that must be awful I'm fair enough so
for them lot fair player would you call
them people who are just [__]
hipsters called a [__] university and
I've had to spliffs and all of a sudden
that independent and you can't put your
[__] opinion on me and all that
though may you're just a cliche your
walk and [__] cliche so you don't
around okay very cliche you think a
wrong the King very cliche no I think
that they're just there what you're
seeing is to submit them field but and
I'm saying alright there's some people
who emotionally want to be made to feel
better but there are some people who are
just wanting to be different they want
it to be special
I'm listening to this music right now on
I saw different although yeah and that's
my thing no one else lessons that that
laws were agreed that lot they can get
the [__] do you think you ever like that
I think we all go through periods of a
life where we are Clichy ation I was we
all do but the comes a time where you've
got to grow the [__] up and I think when
you're at year there's a lot of people
that unit that just pisses off a little
bit do you think though you just get
pissed off
with the minority of people who go to
you need a vocal minority yes that's
what I'm saying the majority who I just
got there for a good education what a
[__] guard Oh for a few parties crack
on that's absolutely fine
can that mainstream well no it's it's
not that it's just it I understand that
that makes sense to me I can understand
how I would end up doing that life no
problem do you think it scares you a
little bit the other stuff but not at
all yeah don't you're not scared of the
world changing get a little bit worried
about the world change not all right I
love your taking the stone a really
weird turn as if I am frightened of
change and it's change that it's not at
all no you're not worried about that I
think as long as that what's inside here
doesn't change
whatever happens outside of here is
irrelevant so what if that person
doesn't have the words just saying
what's inside here as I've just said if
people are they don't know what they are
then I can empathize that almost be
awful but for these cliche hipsters who
are just oh I've heard them on the tree
and I'm up on the [__] pisses off on
the train children say I'm making on the
train oh do you know how they talk in
that month that's how the name drop in
our wall Bob Bob Geldof wouldn't call me
a camera here Marissa's going to New
York she's on a photography course no no
you wouldn't need a that's not they
wouldn't say that would they say
Marissa's going to New York
Marissa's on a photography course right
she she can't be honest I was right
though because she can't be an applause
can she do you know in other languages
they're trying to phase out the gender
of the language yes we German are deadly
back and masculine feminine role neutral
that's all the whole language is male
female or some people talk about that
not having Manuel not referring to it as
male and female because it is a bit
weird well male and female I don't get
it at some of us aren't we are what if
we're not off wrong that no point naught
naught naught 1 % of being born with
poor thing what do you think though
that's a minority that you're making
sounds smaller than it is I pretty sure
if we did the [__]
mus like pretty sure would be a massive
minor a tiny minority do you think
that do you think though that do you
think at all your masculinity is so
linked to your identity that you find it
little bit difficult sometimes when
other people challenge that no not at
all
if you ever had your masculinity
challenged never I thought you was
laughing and ever
no I thinks and what what is that what
hole does someone challenge it up
muscularly ways that do you think I
don't know how someone would what would
what would someone say I guess they put
they'd make they'd met they'd ask you
things that would maybe make you
question whether the way that you'd set
your thought processes up were what
flawless a lot of them for but do you
think some people are over wedded to
their sense of our agenda so there they
are
they identify so much as being a man
that if someone challenges that I've
sort of been around some of those people
who are like don't you know don't don't
touch me
but some people get very upset if I make
a joke like the main gay mm-hm
and I find that quite quite funny yeah I
think if you're really comfortable with
who you are then you won't be offended
by that but I think that some people say
whether it be spirit or soul or just
your brain that some people are
naturally more masculine in thinking in
emotions and some people are more
feminine and because of that some people
if you put a masculine brain or soul or
spirit in a female body you that's when
you get women who you know they come
across as butch if people say like that
you know but sometimes when you put a
really masculine thought brilliant
spirit all of that in a male body they
just come across is maybe trying too
hard so do you think people it's more
because that's what I was wondering you
see things more just about understanding
than disagrees I think people get the
wrong idea about me that I'm really a
super masculine blog like I really not I
don't I don't know what I kind of look
like I am and I speak like I am you did
refuse to eat pho yesterday
what's up that suit we have for lunch I
look a bit what it just I live out of it
we didnít know yeah I've got another
thing that we love so thing that's just
they look weird you had a pie you never
pay a sausage a mushroom sauce a
machinist and apart I don't know I think
I'm pretty comfortable but like so I've
worked with gay fellas before
yeah I've been you got loads of gay
friends now I'm not doing that alright
we've got loads of friends from insert
ethnicities like slash gender slash
[__] whatever no I'm just saying I
never feel intimidated nervous in any
group of people you put me in really hmm
because I'm just comfortable with who I
am it's not about being masculine or
feminine anything like that it's I know
who the [__] I am because I had to learn
at a really young age why cuz I had a
grow fast you know I had find out who I
was quick and I went through some dark
times I think when you've been through
that you just you [__] find out who
you are if you also find out who your
friends are you find out a lot when you
go through [__] do you think stuff is
inherently good or inherently bad
yeah just asking random questions though
I thought no because you said you went
through some dark times like some people
you know odd you think you can find yeah
now that I look back on it I'm better
off for the [__] that I've been through
than if I never I was a complete [__]
an arrogant spoiled self-centered prick
and then we went on the last in the
whole trip when I went through the bad
times it made me more aware of other
people's feelings and that made me so I
even recently and I've changed recently
I look back at the old podcasts and how
much I used to interrupt and I was more
worried about being entertained and then
listening to what people were saying
don't get us wrong you always want to
put on a good show and you all want
people to enjoy what they're watching
but what I'm saying is I could have been
our listening until Nicky Aris came on
the podcast and with Nick the way he
spoke
I didn't I just thought about what he
was saying and took it all on board and
learned from what he was saying because
I was a man who's been through some real
[__] and I can learn a lot from him and
what I realized was when I listened it
wasn't a boring show it wasn't none of
that all those fears were gone and then
I learned from that in future all right
you have to give people a fair crack of
the whip and also pickier chances two in
a row for also interrupt them with good
reason and make sure that you asking a
question that is going to get more from
them so just little little things can
make you learn a hell of a lot that that
two hours changed me forever what would
you say to someone who is it questioning
their own identity having watched this
video I think everyone should crush on
who they're all the full not well you
know it's only done good things for me
and another thing is if your question
and who you are then your heads are like
your [__] arse like I sometimes I
watch interviews with people and I like
to watch interviews with people from
different walks of life so body building
like a body builders are a funny lot
because their whole persona highway is
their whole the job is lifted weights
but it's not like strongman where you've
got a lift weight so you can be the
strongest car there athletically you've
got to lift weights
you've got to die it down and you've got
to make yourself look great till you get
on stage you've got as much muscle and
it's low body fat as possible so and
it's almost like a bit of a beauty
contest in 1910 it each [__] it is so I
respect the grind because lifting
weights is a hard craft and diet ins
[__] hard as well so to go through
that is I respect that
but when you're on stage and you're in a
tiny little ant bit under way it draws
certain personality types into that life
some of them are beasts but some of them
are a bit vain so I was watching one
guy's interview and recently I was I got
so much to learn about life you mate
yeah it's more life than this image that
you're one day this is all not going to
be here you need to have more to you
than what meets the eye and I thought if
he was questioning himself
truthfully he would not pay so pain I'm
not saying all bodybuilders it's just
this one guy who could it could have
been anything but I just chose that
because it was a recent video do you
think he could be a bodybuilder me nah I
love bodybuilding growing up like a
Dorian Yates is a really big inspiration
but and he was an actual just beast of a
man I'd love to get him on the show I've
met him before
but the diet may is where I too much
really because someone what you lie to
me is a bodybuilder watch their diet so
like you'll get up the more they have
porridge great they'll have egg whites
oof but a lot of it may be porridge with
no water no sugar
nice tanked yeah well sorry no milk
rather so everything is going to be
pretty strict you know you know it's the
same thing you're basically living out
the hard bit isn't the day I would say
it's the groundhog day overall every day
is the same food it's the same tuna
brown rice brown pasta the three
potatoes and I think after the first day
you might enjoy it you'd probably like
it but after four four months variety
will be you'll be back in for it so I
think that that is what an adoring it
said that a you have dreams about
sausages and not freely nope don't not
even go there yeah he'd wake up thinking
he'd eaten a load of like bad food for
him okay I'd be like [__] me that I'd
really do that because it plays tricks
on and I narrow my stead that the diet
not Bernie Rhea I just think we should
all question ourselves what do you think
you're going to question next about what
about like yeah because this is the
thing we've talked about this before
well you sort of think I've got life to
get out now now and then you get a bit
old only like God I didn't have a
[__] clue than two years gone by and
you're like so I don't know right now
I'm in this phase where I'm like head
down and I'm just a machine I just want
to put as many videos out as I can and
make good videos like that's my sort of
relentless school in life I feel like
I'm more motivated than most youtubers
out there right now
absolutely given it as much as I can and
it's reaping he rewards well you know
you would have thought it would have
grown quicker to be honestly would but I
tell you what is frustrating I felt like
that gym video I obviously trained me
also in the gym when I did it and I put
hours of hours have edit and into it and
had to slink the [__] cameras in you
make a video like that you have a Paul
Hunter fat on the show who is dropping
knowledge his talent really great
stories and then I do it Newcastle are
champions of the championship video
which was like half an hour sitting
front the camera okay biggest one get
more double the views of those two put
together whatever and I'm like to me
that I understand what people like about
it but to me that not sure the the worst
video of the three so do you think it's
more that your lesson in the next year
is going to be how to harness the
numbers that you have in that area and
getting them over to the other area
maybe of learning the power of of the
numbers that you've got because it's
sort of some people I don't think do
that very well some people do in some of
the new people do different the way that
you've just described it some people go
a lot of people are watching this I'll
do much more of that because that works
whereas what you've done is you've gone
the opposite way if you've said a lot of
people are watching this great I'm gonna
go and do this I I want like I said last
week uh the art form of YouTube I I want
to make videos that I enjoy and I'm
proud of and ultimately when I look back
on YouTube there's going to be a lot of
videos on except me probably shouldn't
amazed that like the runs videos now I'm
not proud of the may hi sky schools I
want to make stuff I'm I'm proud I'm
always going to do regular football
hungover videos because I like doing
them and that people like watching them
yeah and that's my bread and butter but
ultimately it's not I'm not going to
look back and say all that football
hunger was a great memory but when I
look back and say oh I remember sitting
next to a TRS thing and [__] all this
current being through a lot I want those
experiences those memories if I had the
money that was I YouTube was hard
I would not be churning out the same
videos every week I don't I wouldn't do
it if I had all that money though these
are
got I would be pushing myself to let's
go on a make another travel video let's
bring it's less chill right we haven't
got the money I said if I ascended I
want to make videos that when I'm
[__] dead and gone I my kids my
grandkids Oh God grandad was [__] mad
when he look at look at all these things
he went on and did I want to go on a
safari I want to take cameras there I
want to do [__] like that as much as I'd
make a football hung all that I want to
leave behind something where people are
like hey [__] smashed it i I think
that youtubers and I might get that [__]
see in this if you're making a [__] to
an Akash and you're just put in the same
video over and over and over again not
only is it lazy it's just poor I think
do you think some people you see is a
job yeah and do you know it is fair
plate of them for that you're right but
there's more to this than a job for me I
want is the good thing about video I've
lost people in my life who have died and
I looked and I think now that I know
what I know about youtube i all
certainly got if I'd had video of them
it would be really nice and the people
I've got close to me now it's nice for
me to know that they're going to have so
many hours of probably too much of
anything what I'm thinking and I want to
make videos that if I have kids and all
that in the future they're going to be
proud of that I've done charlie how do
we make granddad's videos pride aside no
one else can see who we okay no I mean
not every video is going to be like that
and there's some videos I people are
going to be cringing up but what I'm
saying is I just want to have I want to
put more into it I want to max out I
don't want to just half-ass it and make
the same thing or and look back and
think I could enhance them in yeah why
not let's do it let's smash it Mitchell
and I'm in yeah I thought about that
point aren't you in Apex I know it I'm
um
my mind is made up mate there's not even
a question if I get the money if I am
I'm not going to be a youtuber who
harnesses all the money and grinds the
same stuff out what I want to do is go
make money I want to put it back in the
videos and yeah and make a video that
people are like some people
might look at it and got Georgia on
Safari but for me I'm gonna try and
[__] I want you in that funny helmet
that they have in Jumanji you know that
that guy is like bloody hell anything
get no I don't want to do [__] like that
where people although see your goal this
year in 2017 is 2 for you and I to go on
safari the true Safari hashtag true
safari maybe maybe not this sir but ok
in 2018 your goal is to hey go to the
Russian World Cup and B go on safari or
trying to Solars to a company right I'm
trying right now to if anyone's out
there pitch if anyone's out there
watching and they have if you have
Safari
in your cupboard come with us on a
beautiful adventure I'm just imagining
like herds of weeded wildebeest sweeping
the place are you just running in the
middle of your Moscow push would like a
foot right you'd be right and then
there's me just up a tree or sort of you
know I've contacted people about this
enough about is afar I've contacted
people about doing stuff the true
supporting I just don't what I'm saying
is I look back at what we've made this
year and I feel like up until 2017
I made [__] videos they might have been
funny but to me they were they were [__]
level content absolutely
I don't agree too much right I want
we've never agreed more on anything I
want after I lost some football I
thought there's a video that's good
while a great I'm proud of it ok
direction look at the end well done that
I shot the video that final scene when
you're walking away
I totally plugged right and it was all
my idea anyway the point is did to a tee
that lit a fire under meal let's set the
Sun dad no more [__] normal just
bog-standard videos or OD safari we're
going to do I'm still going to do
football hunger because people want that
but I want an aliens of Africa I want to
add to it we want to have guests on we
aren't a great guests on you what you're
saying is and we'll put it another level
you want to take Nicky eros to South
Africa thing I'm pretty sure it'll
already be any legs traveling mmm-hmm
you you want to go to
the planes of insert country hit
Tanzania Zimbabwe don't push us to
Lauren amid contact what I want to do is
I wanna show you you want to meet I want
to see liar it's brilliant I like lions
I've got a passion for loads I love
lions you want to see live I'm big into
lions so flexible anyway it's not just
about that I just generally want to make
[__] cool videos I'm I don't want to
just do the same old [__] but you're not
I mean would you sleep in a tent with
lions were round no we're like a
lunchbox me especially this [__] you'd
be [__] hacking at me [__] legs
and ass and all sorts now your whole
body would be like the [__] big muck
for those bastards ya know be runnin off
like a like a little fry what a one
skinny little fry they've been making
arm it's all right the big tasty with
bacon you know that's what that's what
you would beat em you'd be nothing but
[__] McDonald's you'd be ronald to
them what would you do if you weren't
now this excites me because i've always
wanted to go on safari so when you said
safari Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing
Bing Bing Bing
once I was got ideas I can see you in a
full Safari kit I see you and I waking
up in a beautiful treehouse I always
want to go true house mate you need tree
houses on Safari the animals are on the
floor you're in the tree house you know
how easy a [__] tell you go and get
up a [__] tree MIT not a problem
I watched it yeah bears can climb
everything yep in the time they're
climbing it no don't shoot the animals I
wanted a little dart noir you've gone
from this left wing cook to next thing
you know Ricky Gervais is tweeting about
you know you can you can definitely you
can say to the line no under three and
if you do I will you're doing that I'll
stand behind you as it launches its
teeth around our neck and or rips you
from the tree and I'll be waving to
going I'll give up the rock don't worry
I'll finish this video true cord you
will finish your
video yeah all I'm saying is let's go to
Africa hashtag true afternoon
you can put true before any of these
series in its great true safari true
Africa true Zimbabwe true for [__] it
we've done it on Madagascar right okay
can be the hip ugh it's not just about
doing safari I just want to make it easy
for me from now on it's all about
getting to the Safari okay okay there's
no strict clubs you can go to that okay
look to prefer I've seen some of the
women out there and sure the tribe women
they're always naked so that's what I'm
worried on the good is that we go there
and you end up the of offending you're
like a prince philip you know i mean i
think they was welcoming me like the
king of the north like i am you know i
mean sure you gonna wear like it
obviously when piltan get scurried
through that you gonna wear like some
sort of Kevin Keegan head mask come we
have the podcaster sure if you want I
think this is yeah remember
hashtag true safari how long we been
gone for probably like an hour and a
half yeah hashtag true Safari don't
forget to start the campaign now tweet
Thompson tweet who else do you want a
tweet virgin well they're not going to
know they're all about
send true Jordy money on a safari but
we're going to set up a patreon
that's the hashtag we if we did a
patreon I think we can mate it and write
tell us in the comments if you're still
watching if you would end up by now but
if you saw what if you saw if you're
sent would you send us to Africa to do
so far we made if we did a patreon would
you pay money to see Brian directed by
someone with a great eye hi go to Africa
on a safari yeah let us know where you
want to see him go let's see what
animals what animals you stipulate you
want in there maybe you want to see him
observing a lion maybe I can show you
right all right I'll be the one
fantastic creatures but not what you're
saying is not in a zoo as well you want
it to be in a place where as far as a
firing don't want to offend people I
don't like the you know lots of it I
want to be out in the wild
I wanna sighing dying us a real
[__] lions fire phone yeah
that's what you want can we get someone
to photoshop me as half-man half-lion as
well but not like in The Wizard of Oz
where he saw no not like a nice dress
that bucket Eddie but I made a real lion
hashtag Carrie Safari hashtag send
Jordi's on safari sure we need to come
is what we will just hit the table all
right flash time true safari I stuck to
you so far is good hash I take is
already on Safari
but much doesn't yeah he's a little
iPhone his last 140 characters longer
trust AG true Safari tweet us and tweet
us hashtag true Safari
followed by the seed be willing to
submit to see his gone Safari
maybe we should we should get the
thumbnail for this video something to do
with me and you like it would be it
would be you and I on Safari you wasn't
good and trying to shoot all you know
but with a dark was just seriously
psychopathic yeah like that dentist and
then you diving in front of the lion
foot all right that's it
hopefully you've enjoyed this absolute
rambling [__] nonsense and you've
also enjoyed what I've said if you have
make sure you let one on the comments
leave a like thanks for watching talk
more about the table and I'll see you
later
hashtag true safari hashtag Theresa
sorry